hmm let's think about speed first I
think that average speed that means over
a whole journey okay
so that means from 0 to 14 how do you
work out speed it's distance on time
we'll see if iran is again all right now
look at the look at the graph actually
you might not even want to think about
the graph what did the mandarine do okay
um no no I Ament pounds please okay how
far did it go what was its total
distance traveled I should put that all
the way up three then it came down three
so that's three plus okay
now by the way take notice even though
the first time it went up and then the
second time I went down so directions
are opposite when you're thinking about
distance it doesn't matter they're both
positive because distance is always
happy positive okay and then you divide
by your time unit so that's okay suppose
that would be meters per yeah that's
right I'm just gonna say time units I'm
gonna stop talking about this silly
yeah devera maybe okay
now that's average speed you said make
sense okay now average velocity hmm
remember velocity is in terms of
displacement okay so what was the total
displacement from zero to fourteen well
it started at my hand and it ended up my
handed right so therefore it's total
displacement was tip it came back to
exactly
so it's zero on 14 tonight which is okay
this is making sense yeah okay
now I just wanted to go through one
worth example of how these concepts fit
together before I set you on some very
very simple exercises before we get to
any of the differentiating or anything
like that
okay you just want to be able to
remember what these mean and be able to
interpret them off a graph okay that's
the first key skill that we're gonna get
before we differentiate or integrate
integrating to the real focus so let me
give these out